não adianta ter um diploma e não
responder a um bom dia e por um sistema
educado e não levar isso pra vida porque
educação mas só que se aprende mas é
também o que se ensina é como pega o
conhecimento eo faz ser sabedoria é
prática constante o que se faz no dia a
dia educação é o que nos transforma e
que gera empatia educação também são
valores que forma o caráter é o que faz
o indivíduo perceberá se sem se esquecer
que vive em sociedade é o que põe todas
as vidas em prol do bem comum e
apresenta a possibilidade de não ser só
mais um educação é criar e não só
repetir a estruturar o ser humano para
uma nova forma de existir conhecer
questionar teorizar discutir porque pra
querer mudar o mundo primeiro tem que
querer mudar a si então tratar a
educação como uma bobagem é um tremendo
engano porque precisamos sair do patamar
de um animal que tem uma mente e nos
tornar verdadeiramente humanos educação
arte e cultura não são frescuras são
necessidades porque temos que ser
objetivos mas também temos que acessar a
nossa subjetividade
então deixem que livremente os
precisamos nossa criatividade porque a
beleza da educação é mostrar que os dons
individuais contribuem para a evolução
da coletividade considerado racional sim
mas sem esquecer o amor porque a
educação é um direito e não um favor
[Aplausos]